Theaters are known for their ghosts.
Take The Gooseberry. In 1919, Gideon
Gooseberry was a rising star on the Great
White Way. But on opening night, playing the
lovesick chimney sweep in Ashes to Ashes, a
300 pound sandbag came loose from the rafters and
brained him in the middle of his second act monologue.
Legend has it,
If you don't sweep Gideon's energy off the
stage every night, he'll find a way to curse
your show.
There was the cholera outbreak that tore
through the company of Hamlet in 1949.
John Gielgud's crippling shingles attack during
the Iceman Cometh revival in '88. And now,
the death of Ben Glenroy.
When you make the stage a part of your life,
it can be hard to escape
your personal ghosts too.
Your obsessions, your failures.
Just when you think you've broken free from
your old patterns.
they come back to haunt you.
I know President McKinley... Joy took
everything.
Except you and me.
The guys with the attitude problems.
But we'll be fine.
We have each other.
But what do you do when your future starts
haunting you? The choices you'll never make.
The lives you'll never lead. What's more
dangerous
then someone whose dreams have died?
Howard? What's wrong?
I have something I need to confess.
I killed Ben Glenroy.